All right guys, step one of the perfect prospecting script is who you are and the pattern interrupts.
There's three questions that we're going to ask, but first what we're going to do is we're
going to do a pattern interrupt.
What I mean by that is back when I was doing door-to-door sales, as I like to relate a
lot of these stories, is we would knock on the door knowing people hated us.
People hate door-to-door people, just like your business owners.
These business owners that we talked to, they hate people calling their phone.
They just do not like it.
We got to look at what is everybody else doing and how do we do it differently?
One thing that we would do back when we did door-to-door is we knew we were already at
a disadvantage.
People hated door-to-door people, but there was a specific type of door-to-door that they
loathed and that was magazine guys.
I've never seen a magazine girl, that's why we call it magazine guys.
They were sketchy, they were scammy, they always stole your money.
People just hated them.
One of the pattern interrupts I use, and I'm just giving you an example, is I'd knock
on the door and be like, hey, my name's Nick, I'm with Vivint.
By the way, Vivint's the company I used to work for, by the way, I'd say, by the way,
I'm not the magazine guy, don't worry, and I'd put my hands up like this.
If I got a laugh out of people, I knew I had some air time.
I'm like, yeah, let me show you what I'm doing real quick.
I got right into it, transitioned in, but it was all about interrupting that pattern
instead of just being the guy that's like, hey, my name's Nick, I'm with a company called
Vivint, and we're doing home security, like guys, that is so cringe, okay, and likewise,
and this is the first thing I want to talk about before we get into anything, is the
one thing you're not gonna do is you're not gonna call and drop the name of your agency
and be salesy, okay?
This is a bad, this is what you don't want to do.
Hi, Jake, this is Nick with Evergreen Enterprises, and I'm calling you about lead generation.
Okay, bad, stop, do not do that, okay?
Here's how we're gonna pattern interrupt.
We're gonna look at what everyone else is doing, okay?
Think about it, what's everyone else doing?
Everyone else, home advisor, angelist, et cetera, they're calling and they're saying,
yeah, hey, is this the business owner?
Hey, Mr. Business Owner, and they go into this BS pitch about ranking on page one and
this and that, and it's roundabout and it's all this different stuff.
The way that we're gonna be, we're gonna do this pattern interrupt is we're gonna go firing
right in, asking them questions, okay?
We're gonna be direct and we're gonna ask them questions and we're gonna ask them three
questions.
Our pattern interrupt is intertwined with these three questions, okay?
So, first question that you're gonna ask is you're gonna ask if they do a specific service
within the service.
So, for example, if you're doing concrete, you're gonna say, hey, Jake, Nick here, quick
question, do you guys do patios, okay?
Do you guys do patios and driveways?
Or, hey, Jake, Nick here, do you guys do tree removal or just tree trimming?
Do you guys actually do the removal or do you guys do stump removal, okay?
You're gonna ask a question pertaining to the service, okay?
You almost wanna make it seem like they're gonna think, is this a customer?
Is this a contractor?
Is this, like, they don't know, okay?
Is this a lead gender?
They're not gonna know.
You're gonna pattern interrupt because you're gonna go right into it.
You're gonna take advantage.
Instead of pitching them, you're gonna ask questions, okay?
If someone else wants to pitch, we're gonna ask questions, okay?
Hey, Jake, do you guys do patios?
Awesome, okay?
That's question one.
Ask about the service, okay?
All right, guys, second question.
You're gonna ask that question and then the second question you're gonna ask is if they
cover a specific area.
The best way I've found, yes, you can say, hey, do you cover this zip code, but what
I think is better is knowing the area and using, like, a suburb name.
That's like, it's gold.
So, for example, I live in a city called St. George and if you look at the map, you're
gonna see there's a main city, St. George, then I live in Washington, technically.
It's actually St. George, but everyone would say I live in Washington.
Then there's a place called Santa Clara.
These are technically cities with their own zip codes, but within St. George, okay, I
live in this area called Little Valley, okay?
Everyone just calls it Little Valley.
So what I would say, like, let's say I was targeting Vegas.
After I asked, hey, do you do patios, cool, awesome, and you guys cover Summerlin, right?
Like, I'm targeting Vegas, but I'm gonna ask, do you guys cover Summerlin?
Now what this is gonna do, it's, first of all, again, they're just like, what the heck?
Secondly, you wanna make sure that this customer is gonna be interested in that lead, okay,
because it's in Summerlin.
Now don't ask about some stupid area.
Ask about the area the lead is in, okay?
So if the lead is actually in Las Vegas, go ahead and ask about the street.
Hey, do you guys cover Silver Beach Circle?
That's the street I live on.
Do you guys cover Silver Beach Circle, okay?
They're like, what, where's that?
Zip code's 84790, okay, cool, yeah, yeah, yeah, we do.
Okay, that's question two.
Question one is a question about the service.
Question two is a question about the area.
Question three, you're gonna ask them how far out they are, okay?
Okay, awesome, last question for you.
How far out are you with giving service?
Like, how far out are you to do an actual trigger mobile?
How far out are you pouring concrete?
I know it's really busy, like, are you guys gonna be able
to take anything before this decade's over?
Like, sometimes I'll joke.
Can you guys actually cover, can you get to something
before the end of this fiscal year?
Like, holy crap, like, I'll kind of joke to them.
They're like, oh, yeah, yeah, we are a little backed out.
And they're like, oh, two months.
Oh, no problem, not a big deal.
And then I'll usually say, what about for an estimate?
Like, what if I just need an estimate?
Like, how far out are you?
Oh, we can do that by the end of the week.
We can do that in 24 hours.
We can do that next week, cool, okay?
And these are what you're gonna do.
You're gonna ask these three questions
and then you're gonna do a miniature transition, okay,
into the second step.
Now, I don't wanna confuse you
because I told you that there's four main parts to this,
right?
Who you are, which is part of the pattern interrupt,
what you're doing, okay, damn good reason, the deal,
and then I said transition, and now I'm telling you
there's miniature transitions, there is.
Between each one of these steps,
there's just these miniature transitions
because you don't wanna just pause, okay?
So you get done, okay, cool,
it's 24 hours to give an estimate.
And then what you're gonna do is you're gonna transition
into why you're calling.
Awesome, Jake, so anyway, the reason I'm calling you,
okay, you're gonna get into why you're calling
and that's gonna be, that's gonna segue us
into the next step.
So, guys, don't be, recap, don't be salesy,
don't use your agency name, just get to the point.
Our pattern interrupt is we're gonna ask three questions,
bang, bang, bang, and we're gonna transition
into why we are calling,
and we're gonna be giving a damn good reason
why the hell we're calling.